[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH THOMSON: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much for joining
us here in the audience
and on the Livestream.
My name is Sarah.
I head up business development
for indie games on Google Play.
KOBI GLICK: Hi.
I'm Kobi.
I'm a product manager
for Google Play.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Hi.
I'm Milena, an engineering
manager on Google Play.
We're here to talk to you about
some cool tools we're launching
in Google Play Developer Console
to help you better release
your apps and games.
We want to make sure you
can launch with confidence,
and better target your apps and
games with the right devices
in a way that makes great
experiences for all your users.
We'll start with a quick
recap of everything
that changed in this
area in the past year,
followed by talking about
some big improvements we've
made to the release management
flows in Google Play
Console in the past year.
We will then go on to
announce new features, changes
to app signing, new
device catalog and device
targeting tools.
We have heard that
some of these areas
are the ones where you
would like to see feedback
and insights from Google most.
So we're very excited to
show you what have built.
KOBI GLICK: So before we
get to the new features,
let's start with a quick recap
of what happened in this space
in the last year.
So exactly a year
ago, at Google I/O,
we launched open beta,
a new way for users
to discover your apps
running beta on Google Play
and join them.
Users can find your app, search
them, join the beta directly
from the Store Listing
page, and leave you
with product review, which you
can see in the Play Console.
Open beta is a great way for
you to test your new updates
before you launch them
live to your users.
So this open beta allows
you to really scale
to programs in Play.
And in the last
year alone, we've
seen more than 100 million
beta testers on Google Play.
There's another number which
we're really excited about,
which is a 4x growth in
the number of apps running
a large beta program on Play.
We get great feedback
from a developers,
like WhatsApp telling
us how open beta allows
them to get critical feedback
from millions of beta testers.
It allows them to experiment
with new features.
And it's one of the
key ways they're
able to deliver such an awesome
messaging experience to so
many users globally.
And we get this
feedback from Tim Sehn,
VP of engineering at Snap.
By the way, Snap with one of the
early adopters of beta testing
on Google Play.
They used it for more
than four years now.
Mr. Sehn tells us
how open beta allows
them to deliver such a
stable op experience,
and is key to their ability
to innovate with new app
experiences.
SARAH THOMSON: So together
with those changes,
we've also launched a developer
program called Early Access.
Has anyone here given
Early Access a try?
Yeah?
A couple of hands?
If you haven't, I highly
recommend you to check it out.
So this is a program that will
allow you to put your apps
or games in front
of early adopters
while your game is
still in development.
So the audience
of early testers,
they're going to be
able to provide you
with really valuable feedback.
We've captured and continue
to grow a significant user
base of highly
engaged users that
are more than
willing to give you
that detailed granular
feedback around how your game
or how your app is performing.
So currently, we have
25 million users,
and counting, that are actually
leveraging that Early Access
program since last year 2016.
So one great example
here is Omnidrone.
This is developer of Titan
Brawl, and they're from Spain.
And they entered
into Early Access,
and they saw more than 400,000
users enter into the game.
They started by
focusing on engagement.
That was the first thing
they decided to iterate on.
They then went on to
iterate on retention
and, finally, monetization.
So with Early Access,
they were able to improve
their engagement rate by 50%.
I mean, that's a
really meaty number.
And then later,
monetization went up by 20%.
This was even before they
actually launched publicly.
So we're really elated to be
able to see these Android-only
tools and services move
the needle in a really
meaningful way towards the
success of their game's launch.
And Omnidrone has told us
that, within Early Access,
they were able to get enough
traffic into their game
to really analyze and
improve their retention,
as well as take on
their marketing assets
and test that in-store
experiments even before going
live.
They also told us that
that private feedback
was invaluable.
You see, one of the great
features about Early Access is
that users cannot rate your
game or app at that time.
So all that great feedback
you're getting from them
does not actually impact
your store ratings.
It's helped them to improve
their game experience based
on that user feedback, which is
always a really great practice
to follow.
MILENA NIKOLIC: The
launch of Early Access
is just one way in which
Android and Play are continually
evolving.
In order to keep pace with
this and in order to give you
guys the tools to use all
the functionality we built
to do its full potential,
we have recently
overhauled the entire
release management section
in the Google Play Console.
App releases replays
the previous APK page
and introduced some pretty
significant changes in the way
how you prepare
your next release
and roll it out to users.
Firstly, we
introduced the concept
of a "release" and the
consistent terminology
throughout the flow,
including things
like "rollout" or "artifact."
Is anyone in the
audience using MultiAPK?
Yep.
Few.
SARAH THOMSON:
Yeah, quite a few.
MILENA NIKOLIC: So
concept of release
is generally useful, but
especially so for you guys.
It gives you a holistic
weight, look at all the APKs
that are active at the
time in a holistic way.
And also to see which one
of them were added now,
and which ones were carried
over from previous releases.
One more important
change is the ability
to separate the
release preparation
process from its rollout.
Previously, you had
to do this weird dance
where you upload some new APKs,
you deactivate the old ones,
and then you have to publish
the whole lot at once.
Now, you can create
a draft release
and save it in various
stages of completion.
You can then go for
lunch, come back,
make some other
changes in the Console,
and only roll it out when
you're really ready and sure.
One of the primary
goals of the new flow
was to enable you to
release with confidence.
We got plenty of
feedback from developers,
like yourselves, that
they're being scared
to publish because
they're not sure what
are going to be the
consequences to their existing
and new users.
We also got some feedback that
some of our error messages
are not very clear.
So these were critical as
we were designing new flows.
We made sure that
everything is much more
explicit in the new flows.
We now provide
confirmation options
at various points
in the flow, which
reduces the risk of accidentally
doing a bad or unintended push
for your users.
For example, we now
have a new page,
which allows you to review the
release before you roll it out.
This page will
highlight any issues,
and warn or even block you,
depending on the severity.
As part of this
process, we actually
changed some of the previously
very strict rules around how
we decide to warn or block you.
This especially
applies to things
like upgrades and targeting
across the Android device
space.
At the same time, we
added some new rules
to give you more visibility into
various other things that could
go wrong with your release.
For example, we now
warn you if you're
introducing a your
permission, which
will reduce your
app's update rate,
or when you are excluding some
devices which you previously
targeting.
KOBI GLICK: Another
change we made
with the new flow is
making staged rollout front
and center.
Now, we love staged rollout.
We think it's a great way for
you to confidently release
your updates to users.
You start with a new seed.
If it performs correctly, you
update until you hit 100%.
In the new flow, we made
the UI front and center.
It's very easy to
set staged rollout.
We also show you
how many devices
you will target with each
percentage of the rollout.
And one feature that we already
got some positive developer
feedback on is the new ability
to set custom percentages,
like the 3% you see right here.
Since launching
the new flow, we've
seen a number we're
really excited about.
We've seen a 50% increase
in the number of developers
that are using staged rollout.
We love seeing this.
Staged rollout is a really
recommended best practice,
and many over top developers
use it practically
to release each one
of their app updates.
There's some other
really cool features
that we launched as
part of the new flow.
For example, you can see
a log of your release.
So when you push to
5%, 10%, or 100%,
you can see a history of all
your historical releases.
And one feature we
think is really cool
is your ability to download
historical APKs from the Play
Console.
So if you're trying to
reproduce a bug from one
of your previous releases,
you go to the Play Console
and you download that APK.
Moving forward, we're
getting ready for the world
beyond the APK.
Starting today, and
you probably heard
the announcement earlier
in the developer keynote,
we're opening publishing
of Android Instant Apps
from the Play Console
using a very similar flow
to the [INAUDIBLE]
you're all familiar with,
with updating your
regular installed apps.
So it should be very
easy for you guys
to come to the Play Console and
publish your Android Instant
Apps starting today.
If you want to hear
more about that,
come to the session intro to
Android Instant Apps tomorrow
1:30 PM, right here on Stage 2.
Now there are two features
that are coming soon,
and we think you'll be
pretty excited about.
If you're using our publishing
APIs to programmatically push
your app updates, soon,
we'll expose a new endpoint
for releases, allowing you to
push the change to the Play
Console But then go
to the Play Console
you like, look at
the validation pages
that Milena mentioned
before to understand
the state of your release, and
only then make the publishing
action from the Play Console
And then also with the best
tradition of Google, launching
and iterating, once we launched
the new flow, we heard your
feedback loud and clear
how we should further improve
the process around release
notes.
Or as we call them, What's New.
We know that today, it's a bit
of a time sink for you guys,
especially if you
manage release notes
across multiple languages.
Therefore, I'm happy to let you
know that very soon, like you
see here, we will
offer you a new format
allowing you to edit all
your release notes offline.
And then with a single
copy and paste action,
move into the Play Console with
a single click of a button.
We think it will
be a big time saver
for you guys and a
feature you'd really like.
So we've had a few developers
now using the new flow
and sharing their
experience with us.
For example, Freeletics here,
developer of health and fitness
apps, tells us that the new
Manage Releases page gives them
a greatly improved status
overview of their release.
And Deliveroo's pretty
pleased with the ease
of use and convenient
overview that they now
get with staged rollouts.
Now, they can see
exactly how many
installs that they are expected
to get to that stage rollout,
while providing them with a
whole new and exciting level
of control.
OK, so now you guys can actually
roll out your app and game
to users with higher confidence.
But you still want to understand
how your release is actually
performing.
Well, this is why we're
launching another great feature
right here, the
Release Dashboard.
Here, you'll be able to
track your release health.
So for example, you can see
what your crash rate is doing,
what the ratings
changes look like,
or how is your uninstall
rates fluctuating.
This is based on
hourly aggregated data.
So it gives you a
really powerful way
to keep track of your release
as it's getting adopted.
You can compare the
release performance
to a previous release,
which we think you guys are
going to really love.
I mean, what do you think?
Does that sound cool?
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
So hopefully, you already
know that if you're
running a staged
rollout, you can actually
halt it at any time if you're
detecting any kind of issues.
So for instance,
if you're noticing
your crash rate is
going up or there's
a big spike in uninstall
rates, you can react quickly.
If you halt a staged rollout,
and the users that didn't get
that update, they won't get it.
So rest assured.
Then you can focus on
investigating and fixing
those bugs before
releasing the new build.
So if you guys want a deeper
dive into that awesome Release
Dashboard I was just
referencing, along
with some other cool
features that we're launching
to help you improve
your app health,
go check out Making data
on Play work for you,
tomorrow, 1:30 PM,
over at Stage 1.
MILENA NIKOLIC:
OK, let's move on.
As Android developers, you're
signing key ensures security
and integrity of your app.
That makes it very important.
Lost or compromised keys
are a very serious issue.
I hope that this didn't
happen to any of you.
But in fact, this is one of the
most commonly-reported issues
to operations team.
This is why we
very excited to be
announcing another
important feature,
Google Play app signing.
If you join this program, you
let Google Play manage your key
and sign your app before
delivering it to users.
For new apps, we can simply
generate a key for you.
For existing apps,
we provide you
a flow through which
you can securely
hand over the keys to us.
After that, you don't have to
worry about balancing security
and convenience of access by,
for example, storing your key
in a version control system.
You can even delete it.
Apps uploaded to
Play will still be
signed, but with a separate
upload key, which we use
as a secondary authentication.
This one can always
be replaced if needed.
SARAH THOMSON: OK, so first
of all, this guy right
here is super-excited about it.
I just want to point that out.
Thanks for the thumbs-up.
We've had several
partners actually using
Google Play app signing for a
while now, and they love it.
Surprise.
Here, Robin Hood speaks
to the layer of safety
that we've added,
while at the same time
it's just eliminated that worry
of having lost or stolen keys.
And I guess I don't have to ask.
I mean, how cool is this?
Pretty cool.
MILENA NIKOLIC:
It's pretty cool.
SARAH THOMSON: Yeah.
MILENA NIKOLIC: OK, so
now that Google Play
is signing your app, you can
probably guess what comes next.
We can also start
optimizing it on our behalf.
The first optimization
that we've
started with a few
partners is resource
stripping optimizations.
If you opt into
this, you can give us
a universal, or a
so-called Fap APK,
based on which we
will automatically
generate the device-specific
APKs by stripping
redundant resources for native
libraries and screen densities.
For example, when delivering
your app to an [INAUDIBLE]
phone, we will make sure we
strip out all the x86 native
libraries.
This way, the APK will send
out to users [INAUDIBLE]
smaller, taking less bandwidth,
less space on their disk,
without requiring you
guys to use MultiAPK.
This way, we're seeing
over 20% APK size savings
with some of the partners.
So make sure you
opt in and try this
out when it becomes available.
We are very excited
about Google Play app
signing and all the app
optimization we can bring you
on top of it in the future.
This program is optional, but we
really hope you decide to join.
To learn more about app signing
with Google, its security
benefits, and the
side gains you can
get with the various
optimizations,
please come to the How
to secure and optimize
your app with Google Play app
signing talk tomorrow at 2:30
PM on Stage 1.
KOBI GLICK: OK.
Now I want to tell you a story.
A real story.
When I joined Google
few years ago,
my friend, who is an
Android developer,
asked me for just one thing.
Can we do anything about
this page you see right here?
You're probably all
familiar with this page.
So I asked him, why?
What's wrong with this page?
And he's like, well, there are
thousands of devices there.
There's very little
info on each device.
Many devices actually have
the same name again and again,
and managing devices in
general is busy work.
Now, the Android ecosystem
has grown so significantly
because it offers
different devices
with different capabilities
at various price points.
At the same time, it's
important that users
don't get an app or a game
that their device doesn't
have the hardware to support.
You know what happens.
The user gets annoyed
because the app
doesn't work on their device.
And then you get annoyed
because the user leaves
a one-star review, blaming
your app for something
that isn't really your fault.
It's really important
for us that you're
able to deliver great
experience to your users.
And to be able to do that, we
need to provide you visibility
into the device space.
It's especially important
for game developers
because we're aware that
you guys, in many cases,
build your games according
to a reference device spec.
Therefore, we're very excited
to announce that, today, we're
launching a new device
catalog in the Play Console.
Woo-hoo.
[APPLAUSE]
With this new and
shiny catalog, you
can see the full hardware
spec for thousands
of devices that were certified
by Google for the Google Mobile
suite of apps.
You see here what we
call the card view.
But we also provide
you with a list view,
allowing you to run all
kind of quick operations
on a set of devices.
Take a moment to compare the
old UI versus the new UI.
Pretty awesome.
OK, so what do you get
in this new catalog?
So first, you get
a full device spec.
You get information like RAM,
system on chip, GPU, CPU,
screen size and density,
and the supported Android OS
versions for each one of
those thousands of devices.
You can search devices by
any of these attributes.
For example, you can run the
search that you see right here.
What we call the filter.
You can search for all devices,
for example, with Android SDK
24 plus and a specific GPU.
And one of the
features I like best.
Every time you
search for devices,
and we show you one
or many devices,
we also show you your app
performance on those devices.
So we show you how many
installs, how much revenue,
and what's the average rating
that those devices contribute
to your app.
This is super-important
when you're making decisions
like prioritizing bug fixes
or making device exclusion
decisions.
When we gave the new catalog
to Pixelberry Studios,
one of our testing
partners, it helped
them avoid making a
big mistake on day one.
Literally on day one.
So they were about
to exclude a device.
But actually, with
the new catalog,
they suddenly saw that it
has meaningful installs, 4.6
rating, and actually some
meaningful revenue, too.
So they avoided excluding
it, and therefore avoiding
making a major mistake.
Pixelberry Studio
tells us this tool
will be a game changer
for the studio.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Cool.
Another really cool feature
of the device catalog
are device groups.
It is quite common to
have multiple devices
with the same brand name,
but different system on chip
configurations.
For example different
Samsung Galaxy 7s.
We've heard multiple
times from developers
that it's very
hard to figure out
what's happening to those
cases, and especially
to debug performance issues.
So in our new catalog, we group
all those devices for you,
while allowing you to drill down
and see each individual device
SKU separately.
If you want to
exclude a device, you
can either exclude a
specific SKU or an entire set
of devices for a single group.
Now, one big addition
we're introducing
are device exclusion rules.
This is the ability to
exclude devices based
on performance indicators.
For example, if you're
developing a rich graphics
game, you may struggle
to get it to perform well
on devices with less than
512meg or 1 gig of RAM.
In which case, you
may want to exclude
the entire group of devices
with less RAM than that.
Or if you discover
a specific bug,
you may decide to exclude all
devices with a specific system
on a chip configuration.
This allows you to
stop deployment only
to problematic devices
while you work on a fix,
and deploy the fix to
all the affected users
as soon as it gets ready.
When you create an exclusion
rule, we also, similar to what
Kobi was earlier
saying, we show you
which devices you're
about to exclude,
how much installs you're
making from all those devices,
and how much revenue
you're making.
Which is pretty
important information
where you're making a
big decision like this.
And then to save
you some more time,
we also let you copy the
list of excluded devices
from another one of
your apps, just to make
it a little bit quicker.
KOBI GLICK: We already heard
from a bunch of developers
that they really
love this feature.
SARAH THOMSON: Oh yeah?
MILENA NIKOLIC: Cool.
So we know you want to exclude
a few devices as possible.
After all, Android is so great
because it has a vast reach,
and because users
everywhere around the world
are using a great and
diverse device set.
However, we do acknowledge
that sometimes, you
need to exclude
devices temporarily
or even permanently.
And we want to make sure we have
the right feature set allowing
you to make such
important decisions,
including validations to make
sure you don't shoot yourself
in the foot by over-exploding.
You can see, for
example, that EA
are using new tools to launch
more confidently and ensure
players get better
experiences across all
of their supported devices.
Similarly, Space Ape Games
shared feedback with us
where they found a great
way of incorporating
new device targeting tools to
reduce costs and improve API.
SARAH THOMSON: So I'd like
to build a little bit off
of what Milena was just
speaking to there around device
exclusion.
So Big Fish, one of
our testing partners
for the device catalog,
has been really
terrific in sharing a ton
of feedback and insight
into the tool as
they've been using it.
We collated their
experience into a case study
that we're going to
share with you today.
But first, I wanted to
take a little bit of a step
back and let you know that
we had some reservations
as a platform, as Google
Play, that we were
a little bit concerned that
developers might support less
devices as a result of this.
But Big Fish illustrates
that this is, in fact, going
to facilitate the opposite.
It's going to allow you
to support more devices.
So as we went down that
rabbit hole with them
with their first days of
interacting with the catalog,
two recurring themes popped up.
Precision and quality.
Let's start with precision.
So Big Fish's mantra is
actually to publish games
to the widest audience
possible, and using restrictions
as a last resort.
But my favorite quote from
them is right here, which is,
"We can now take a
scalpel into the operating
room instead of a hatchet."
KOBI GLICK: It
sounds safer to me.
SARAH THOMSON: It's
like, what a visual.
As I'm sure many
of you can relate,
developers have been
going to the far reaches
of the Internet, scattered
across to leverage
several third-party
sources of information
around Android devices
and their specs for years.
The Big Fish team really loves
the consolidated Android device
models and grouping,
where they can also see,
as Kobi was speaking about,
that install revenue and ratings
numbers for each device.
This allows you to make
more informed decisions.
So one specific
example that they
gave us was that, in the
past, they had this running
list of low-end device
exclusions, probably
sounds familiar, for a
particular business unit.
They were forced
to search and check
against this running
list for every new title.
And given that Big Fish is an
extremely prolific game maker,
this was a huge
pain in the butt.
So they can now set that
one-time RAM-based device
inclusion rule, and import
that into every new game,
they launch moving forward.
That means no running internal
lists, no manual labor.
So this newly-found
precision is leading
to some serious
efficiencies for them.
And we're excited to provide
you with a lot of oil
to grease those
wheels for your team.
KOBI GLICK: We
actually asked Big Fish
how they anticipated the
new catalog will help
them to include more devices.
So they give us a real example.
In one very tricky
device group, they
had to use the hatchet
approach that Sarah
mentioned before,
and exclude 12%
of the devices in that group.
With the new catalog,
they estimate
they can take down
this 12% to 2%,
which means including
many more devices.
This is a huge win for
both developers and users.
SARAH THOMSON: So let's
move on to quality now.
Since quality is near
and dear to our hearts
here at Google Play, we
knew that giving you guys
a significant and
centralized device catalog
would surely lead
to improved quality.
In particular, the catalog can
empower you, the developer,
to create a consistent
and elevated user
experience for Google Play
users across a broad array
of devices.
The diversity of Android devices
enables your games and apps
to reach audiences that no
other gaming platform can do.
We know that this also, though,
presents some unique challenges
related to that diversity.
MILENA NIKOLIC: I think
Big Fish said it best.
We're able to be more
proactive in our device
support of new launches, and
more quickly able to respond
to real-world problems.
SARAH THOMSON: The Big Fish team
gave me this pointed feedback
of how the device
catalog is enabling
them to react and solve
device-specific issues
in record time.
It's given them more confidence
in their early game rollout
process, knowing that
they can iterate quickly
against device support as well.
So for example, they have
a game, Cooking Craze,
that is currently in
open beta right now.
They decided to launch it with
actually known performance
issues, because they knew that,
while it was out in the wild,
they could also look
for unforeseen issues.
With launching earlier, and that
review feedback not counting
towards their overall ratings
that I spoke of earlier,
they could pluck out those
iffy devices and disable
support for those
devices in the meantime.
That then allows them to iterate
regarding device support more
quickly.
Then they were able
to insulate their game
from negative reviews.
And that would, in turn, not
affect the discovery algorithms
on Google Play.
So this is a really
amazing way for them
to set themselves up for the
best possible global launch
right out of the gate.
And we understand that you
only get one chance at launch.
While you guys are increasingly
focused on creating gaming
experience with
lasting power beyond,
we understand that that launch
window is still really crucial.
It's the foundation that sets
your game up for success.
Since the early days
of the device catalog,
we're excited to hear
of other new ways
that this service
will positively
impact your apps and games.
As we roll out more
broadly, please do
share your stories with us.
We'd love to understand how the
device catalog is contributing
to the success of your game
and your business overall.
KOBI GLICK: So it's
great to see how
open beta, where we
opened the talk with,
connects to the device catalog.
Today, we've shown you
a bunch of new launches,
new tools we're launching
in the Play Console.
And we also showed you
how developers use them
to find success on Google Play.
We showed you our
new release flow,
giving you more confidence and
clarity as you make up updates.
We showed you the
new validation step,
which makes sure
you avoid making
major mistakes before
you release your app
updates to users.
We showed you how we made
staged rollout front and center,
allowing you to see the
number of targeted devices
and set custom percentages.
We showed you how you can
save your release as a draft,
and then come back later to
launch it when you're ready.
We also showed you the
new Release Dashboard,
allowing you to keep track
of your release performance
in real time, making
sure you react
to issues as they show up.
And then we've also mentioned
that, starting today, you
can publish your Android
Instant Apps directly
from the Play Console.
MILENA NIKOLIC: We
continued by talking
about a new program
where Google Play can
take the burden of
signing your app from you.
We talked about the security
benefits and about the size
gains you can get with
the app optimizations.
Last, but not least, we talked
about the new device catalog.
We showed you the rich device
spec, how we group devices,
how we can efficiently search
and filter the catalog,
and how you can see the data
about performance of your app
on a resulting set.
We also talked about
the new rules allowing
you to filter your
app on the store,
based on performance indicators.
And here are some
helpful links if you
want to explore any of
the things we talked about
in more detail.
We are sure you will
like the new features.
And they will help you
release with more confidence,
better understand the
Android device base,
and focus on doing
what you guys do best.
Build amazing apps and games,
and deliver great experiences
to millions of Android
users all around the world.
Thank you
SARAH THOMSON:
Thanks, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]